I came out in high school.
And a lot of my extended family kind of cast me out in a way.
I wasn’t really spoken to much after that.
When I first came out I was told that I was too feminine to be a man.
And that made me feel pretty powerless.
Unfortunately I felt that my sexuality was a secret.
Something that was keeping me from love, keeping me from being fully accepted.
When you’re young and you’re dealing with your identity, it’s confusing and tough,
and the way I found my way out of that was by telling people.
When people take away our power,
it’s because they’re afraid of things that are different,
or challenge their systems of belief.
Just because I have to follow somebody else’s arbitrary rules,
doesn’t mean I am less than; doesn’t mean I don’t have a voice.
I just have to get creative.
My power is my authenticity.
What makes me feel the most powerful now
is choosing to give up fear.
My power is perseverance.
I will not apologize for being myself.
You can literally just sit there being queer
and you’re already doing more than most people in this world.
I mean, you’re incredible.
You don’t have to feel scared.
Know that every feeling is impermanent.
This feeling will pass, it is not forever.
I have felt powerless. Everyone feels powerless at some point.
And honey we just got to keep going.
You can’t take my power.
It’s being understood; it’s being heard;
it’s being there for one another no matter what.
Every day is reclaiming that power.
My power is self love.
I think love is the most strong and powerful feeling,
and I think the LGBTQ+ Community has got that locked down.
In solidarity there is power.
Find a community around you who can remind you
of why you are so beautifully queer.
This is our power.
This, this is our power.